un despliegue de ayuda para los más
afectados en una operación de rescate de
emergencia el gobierno de pakistán busca
ayudar a los miles de damnificados que
han dejado las inundaciones consecuencia
de las fuertes lluvias que azotan la
provincia de baluchistán al suroeste del
país allí las lluvias monzónicas han
dejado más de 120 fallecimientos a este
verano según las autoridades en las
últimas horas el primer ministro de
pakistán sobrevoló las zonas más
afectadas y ordenó acelerar las
actividades de socorro
anoche los soldados sacaron a las
víctimas de las inundaciones con la
ayuda de helicópteros del ejército les
dieron algo de comida y les ayudaron a
montar tiendas de campaña para alojarse
pero como no nos queda nada seguimos en
malas condiciones
este se llamará para estar trabajo mi
casa ha sido destruida mi casa el ganado
todo está acabado no tengo ni idea de
dónde llevar a los miembros de mi
familia que empezaron las inundaciones
hemos estado sentados aquí ninguna
autoridad ha venido a rescatarnos no han
enviado ningún tractor ni comida ni
raciones nada hemos estado aquí sentados
indefensión en el coche
la provincia de baluchistán ha sido la
más afectada pero al menos siete puentes
importantes presentan daños lo que
empieza a afectar la economía del país
la vía férrea entre que está y la ciudad
fronteriza iraní saeed an y la autopista
que une esa misma ciudad con el
municipio afgano de kandahar también
quedaron bloqueadas por las fuertes
lluvias e inundaciones una situación que
ha detenido el comercio que transita
entre pakistán con irán y afganistán en
aquí están sufrió las peores
inundaciones de su historia cuando el
monzón y el fuerte deshielo del verano
dejaron dos mil víctimas mortales y más
de 20 millones de damnificados